Y resulta que la psicología sabe mucho sobre estas cosas.
De verdad, mucho.
Pero nunca escuché nada de esto
en las clases de estudios ambientales,
o en las reuniones de acción por el clima a las que empecé a ir,
o en las conferencias internacionales,
donde todos preguntan:
¿Por qué no actuamos más rápido? y ¿qué hay que hacer?
Y esto se ha convertido en mi misión:
tomar conceptos de la psicología
y traducirlos en recursos y herramientas
con el fin de apoyar a quienes trabajan en primera línea para cambiar las cosas.
Y eso aplica a cualquiera, por cierto.
Todos estamos en la primera línea en este momento.
Y considero que, después de años de transitar estos mundos
entre el medio ambiente, el clima y la psicología,
este es el ingrediente faltante en nuestro trabajo
que podría acelerar exponencialmente nuestras capacidades para ser creativos
resistentes, hábiles y valientes,
y todas esas cosas que el mundo necesita de nosotros ahora mismo.
Así que compartiré tres conceptos con Uds.
que considero particularmente revolucionarios
y que dan sentido a este momento para nosotros como humanos.
El primer concepto es lo que llamo nuestra "ventana de tolerancia".
El Dr. Dan Siegel ha postulado que todos tenemos una ventana
relacionada con cuánto estrés podemos tolerar
manteniéndose uno conectado,
lo que los clínicos llamarían "integrado".
Integrados, es decir,
estar en contacto con nuestros pensamientos y sentimientos
y no solo siendo un tanto manipulados.
Todos tenemos un umbral de tolerancia.
¿Y qué sucede al experimentar estrés
más allá de lo que podemos tolerar?
Tendemos a ir al borde de nuestra ventana.
Y por un lado,
podríamos entrar en una especie de colapso,
llamado "respuesta caótica",
que se asemeja a la depresión, la desesperación,
una especie de bloqueo.
Y al otro lado de esa ventana hay una respuesta más rígida:
negación,
ira,
rigidez.
Y cuando eso sucede,
en realidad perdemos nuestra capacidad de estar integrados,
de ser resistentes, adaptables,
todo aquello que queremos ser.
Y esto es totalmente normal,
y está sucediendo en todo el mundo en este momento, ¿verdad?
Todos vacilamos entre estos sentimientos y estas emociones diferentes.
Y, con algo como el cambio climático,
con cada nuevo informe científico,
o documental,
cuando caemos en la cuenta de lo que hacemos
y el impacto que tiene,
colectivamente puede sacarnos de nuestra ventana de tolerancia.
Y perdemos esa capacidad.
Durante años he entrevistado a cientos de personas
de todos los orígenes y afiliaciones políticas,
desde el Medio Oeste de EE. UU. a China,
y hablé con ellas de cómo nos sentimos
en relación a lo que está pasando y no en relación a opiniones o creencias.
Hablamos de lo que sentimos
sobre lo que está pasando con nuestro medioambiente local,
nuestra agua, nuestra tierra, los recursos en general.
Y lo que escucho de la gente en casi todos los ámbitos
es un vínculo.
La gente me dice en algún momento de la conversación:
"Me importa mucho lo que está pasando y estoy increíblemente asustado.
Tengo miedo.
Amo esta tierra, amo los pájaros",
sea lo que sea,
"pero siento que mis acciones son insignificantes.
Y no sé por dónde empezar".
Yo interpreto entre líneas lo que quieren decir:
"Realmente me asusta cambiar.
Le temo a cualquier cambio.
Ni siquiera puedo pensar en eso. Es como impensable".
Y este es el segundo concepto, llamado "doble vínculo".
Un doble vínculo es cuando sentimos que está mal si lo hacemos,
y mal si no lo hacemos.
Y uno está ahí como atrapado.
Es una experiencia humana muy intolerable.
Hacemos todo lo posible para quitárnoslo de encima.
Y toda esa inquietud y preocupación se quedan allí.
Simplemente penetran y quedan soterradas.
Parece que a la gente no le importara o mostrara total apatía.
Y mucha gente que ve la urgencia de la situación piensa:
"Tenemos que motivarlos.
Tenemos que mentalizarlos".
Y nos convertimos en animadoras de soluciones.
O: "Aquí están los hechos. Esto es lo que está sucediendo. ¡Despierten!".
Y estas cosas, en realidad, no son en sí negativas,
ya que necesitamos soluciones y debemos enfrentar los hechos.
Pero sin darnos cuenta, esto puede ser contraproducente
y puede generar más indiferencia e inacción,
lo que resulta muy desconcertante para mucha gente, que piensa:
"¿Qué diablos está pasando?".
Y lo cierto es que esto que ocurre,
lo que sucede, no está tocando la fibra de fondo.
Así que imaginen que uno va a ver a una terapeuta,
con la que tenemos un doble vínculo.
Uno se siente realmente atrapado,
sabe que tiene que cambiar,
y la terapeuta comienza a gritarnos:
"¿No ve Ud. lo que está pasando?
Si no actúa ahora,
se va a enfrentar a consecuencias aterradoras
¿No le importa?
¿Qué le pasa?
¿Qué va a hacer?".
O uno va a ver a un terapeuta porque está triste y apesadumbrado.
Y el terapeuta dice:
"No piense demasiado en eso.
Le diré algunas cosas simples que Ud. puede hacer.
Cosas simples y positivas".
Y dan el asunto por terminado.
Si fuera mi decisión,
despediría inmediatamente a ese terapeuta,
porque un buen terapeuta practica algo llamado "sintonía".
Me gusta mucho este concepto.
Sintonía viene de sintonizar.
Y la sintonía se da cuando nos sentimos sincronizados
porque nos sentimos entendidos
y nos sentimos aceptados por estar donde estamos.
Y sentimos que
tenemos una relación con el mundo de una forma que tiene sentido.
Nadie intenta cambiarnos, avergonzarnos ni juzgarnos.
Y lograr sintonía requiere habilidad.
Si hay mucho en juego,
es muy difícil querer sintonizar con cualquier cosa,
por ejemplo, cuando enfrentamos amenazas muy urgentes.
Pero la paradoja de estos momentos
es que si estamos más sintonizados con nuestra ventana de tolerancia,
somos mucho más capaces de resolver problemas,
de ser creativos, adaptativos,
flexibles,
de ser lo mejor de nosotros mismos.
Y ¿qué si nuestro trabajo por el clima y el medioambiente
estuvo influido por estos conceptos:
la ventana de tolerancia,
los múltiples dobles vínculos
y la sintonía?
Puede parecer un montón de cosas.
Y me dicen todo el tiempo:
"Esto suena muy bien para un contexto clínico,
pero no tenemos tiempo para esto".
Y eso no es cierto.
Porque podemos llevar la sintonía
a cada aspecto de nuestro trabajo en este tema.
Y comienza con nosotros mismos.
En realidad, no se puede lograr sintonía
a menos que uno esté sintonizado consigo mismo.
Lamento decirlo.
No hay forma de evitarlo.
Esto funciona de dentro hacia fuera.
Y se comienza a sintonizar con el "¿cómo me siento?"
y ser compasivo.
Sé que es fácil decirlo,
pero ser compasivo es pensar que estos son problemas difíciles,
que es un momento difícil para el ser humano,
y que estamos despertando.
No soy una mala persona.
Lo que está pasando
trae curiosidad a nuestra propia experiencia,
lo que nos permite sintonizar socialmente.
Esa es la forma en que podemos aplicar esto:
sintonizando, ya sea en grupos pequeños o una persona con otra,
con campañas, estrategias, aulas, cines,
parques.
Allí donde podemos actuar para ser quienes somos,
y nuevamente, esto nos permite avanzar
en el funcionamiento a un nivel superior,
en la función ejecutiva, en la corteza prefrontal,
cuando sentimos que nuestro sistema nervioso puede calmarse
y que los otros nos entienden.
Y la tercera forma es liderar con sintonía,
como líderes e influenciadores,
mostrándonos humanos, reales,
diciendo: "¿Saben qué? Estoy muy asustada.
No conozco todas las respuestas".
¿Se imaginan a líderes diciendo eso?
"No lo sé.
Pero aquí estamos, y todos somos necesarios.
Estamos en esto juntos, y podemos hacerlo".
Ese es un mensaje muy diferente al simple "podemos hacer esto".
Es "Aquí estamos.
Estoy asustada, pero es lo que está sucediendo".
Y lo importante es que este trabajo existe.
Tenemos las herramientas para crear estas condiciones
que nos pueden permitir
ser lo mejor de nosotros mismos.
Y sé, sin duda, al 100 %,
que cada uno de nosotros tiene la capacidad
de enfrentar estos desafíos
con el ingenio, la brillantez y la valentía que tenemos como humanos.
Solo necesitamos cultivar las condiciones conjuntamente.
Nos necesitamos para apoyarnos mutuamente
y permitirnos cumplir con esto.
Eso es lo que necesitamos,
así que respiremos profundamente,
tengamos compasión el uno por el otro
en este tiempo de la historia,
así procesaremos colectivamente estas verdades dolorosas,
estas realidades difíciles.
Hagámoslo juntos.
El mundo está listo para que lo hagamos.
Y podemos lograrlo.
Gracias
(Aplausos)